hey my name is Samuel this is Q&A Sunday
so I'm a property investor and I love to
help and create other property investors
and I've had some questions from people
aspiring to me or maybe just starting
out in property let's see what we got
love your stuff Samuel thank you
regarding article 4 jazz that prevent
new multi let properties or does it just
prohibit new licensed HMOs ie five or
six bedrooms thank you
so one ski all HMOs all Malta let's if
you're moving into an article for area
and you were buying a house a
single-family home and you want to rent
that house out by the room even if you
just want to rent out three rooms in the
house you cannot do that
that's how hardcore article forests so
of course what I do is buy houses
outside of article four areas or buy
houses that are about to become article
four and then I get the grandfather
right so yeah Ohi miles altogether
George says do you think brexit okay
another brexit question do you think
brexit will cause a lot of immigrants to
leave the UK and if so to what extent
will this impact the rental market could
we expect an oversupply of houses to
rent and drop on rental prices so I
don't know because brexit hasn't
happened yet
however I would certainly like to think
that people don't get kicked out of
England I mean honestly I'm all for
having boarders I think that's fine
because it's just every countries got
its own rules and its own bought I think
that's fine that's probably a good thing
but kicking people out that have been
here for years I don't think that's
going to happen and here's why I think
that's going to happen because I think
that it would ruin so many businesses I
mean forget my property business yes
I've got a lot of tenants who are
international students or international
workers but my actual my business is in
my training business like as CEO oh is
from Portugal you know we've got
marketing director is from Poland so
I just like personally I cannot see that
they're going to be kicked out of the
country when they're bringing so much
value to the country that's my opinion
what's going to happen exactly I just
think there be such an uproar my wife my
wife only became British last year like
what would they have done two years ago
just kicked her sent her back to
Zimbabwe Africa I just can't see that
happening I really cannot and I think
that in the UK generally speaking with
such a multicultural connect Honor
Society III can't see it it would ruin
businesses real big businesses real big
businesses and if I was with my investor
hat on only houses I'm not worried about
losing tenants mister maybe they'll beat
harder the amount of illegal immigrants
we have in this country is insane we
have thousands of illegal immigrants I
think they'll tighten up on that for
sure I know Boris is talking about that
but that's my opinion I'm not worried
about it at all to be honest because I
just I just cannot possibly imagine it
but hey if we'll find out I guess on the
31st of October what do you think more
importantly comment below what are your
thoughts on brexit I mean I don't mind
if you're in or out not honestly I mean
I I personally think that most people
that argue about brick sets somewhere in
some out they actually want the same
thing it's just a case of how do we get
there so I'm cool we break sit on
finally breaks it but it'd be
interesting to see what happens so okay
Christina boss I love you Christina I
appreciate all your comments I
appreciate all your posts and I'm sorry
that your book hasn't arrived yet I hope
it's arrived by the time you get this
but Christina says Sonia I'm in the UK
for two years self-employed I went back
to ask to borrow some money from from
them they said to come after one year
should I wait or another people I can
ask to help with this problem okay
Bank he went to the bank don't go to the
bank to ask for money the bank on the
worst person if you're trying to get a
house for like a mortgage I assume
you're talking to mortgage you want to
go to a broker you get a good
broker go onto the property investors
group property investors with Samuel is
is a Facebook group asked to join it
you'll be accepted by the team really
quickly hopefully and that's the
question say hey how do I get in touch
with a good broker and there's loads of
brokers on that I'm sure you don't want
to wait a year you just want to find
another broker here's the thing if you
go to a bank and say can I have money
please for a house that bank might say
no but if you go to a broker that broker
will be able to go to hundreds of banks
and find the one that will say yes for
you so that's my advice all right we'll
just do one more Jeremy Jeremy says hey
Samuel thanks for your amazing videos
and advice
boom you're so welcome thank you can you
advise me on how to put together a great
power team of builders tradesman for a
first time hey Jamie I'm Walter let
please how do you organize them to be
ready for action and time for receiving
the keys
I imagine you can't waste time
especially when you purchase with
short-term bridging loans so true
finding good builders also available
when you need them in an area that's new
to me seems a little daunting how do you
do it
thanks Jess jazz great question and I'm
assuming that you've bought HMO outside
of your area probably because the
numbers stack up so firstly juggerjazz
congratulations on doing that and taking
that leap of faith and taking that step
how do you get builders okay so there's
a few ways you can get builders before
you use a builder I would ask to look at
their previous work because if you go to
a job that they're currently working on
a virtual job they've just finished to
be able to see the standard or at least
asked for pictures it's unit far away
and you've got a team of builders going
in depending on how big the project is I
would probably want a project manager
even if the project manager is just
going to be working on the project for a
couple of months or going down two or
three times a week I wouldn't pay a
fortune but if builders are left on
own devices and they know that you live
three or four hours away they're just
humans and they're gonna not prioritize
your job they're gonna cut corners
they're gonna overcharge you so I
understand why you're feeling a little
bit nervous about it but there are
people even if you just ask for fine go
to you a property investors Network
meeting in the area and find investors
that are are dealing with builders and
just find someone that can just keep it
on it maybe because if you don't know
what you're doing and you're far away
you could do it yourself but it's gonna
be more effort it's gonna be more time
you'd be better to just pay someone to
be a project manager make sure that you
have a a a a an itemized quote so it's a
case of it's not just oil guilt costing
around oil cuz 20 grand you want to know
you want an exact breakdown of of that
quote so for the for the painting in
each room and for the plastering in each
room and what what they charge a new day
rate enough so labor policy plus the
materials you want to know all this and
you also want and deadlines in place as
well so how long when's the deadlines in
a bit and maybe there could be penalties
if they go over the debt if they go over
the deadline you want all this in place
it's not difficult it just it just it's
just one of those things that need to
happen so I wish you all the best with
that if you do need any help please do
reach out to us and also join the
property investors group as well we have
a really really good Facebook group
where we support and help one another if
you've got any more questions for me
Jess if you've got any follow-up
questions drop a comment below ask your
questions I'll do my best to answer as
many as I can
next Sunday don't forget as well we have
daily videos every day I put our new
video so if you're not subscribed to the
channel please do subscribe and turn on
the notification bow so you get notified
every time I put a video out it's a lot
better than watching the TV you'll be
entertained you'll learn and you'll go
ahead and become very very wealthy so
thanks for watching Steve tomorrow peace
out
[Music]